[Music]
the day I got an offer to be a
consultant after college a good friend
told me girl you're done the hardest
part is getting the job that got me
really excited but I also heard this
anxious voice speaking inside my head
that voice is my inner critic who I call
Nancy and Nancy kept telling me Renata I
don't think it should be that excited
you have zero consulting skills Nancy
was right but she calmed down after all
of the training that every consultant
has to get through a few years later
when I met my wonderful partner John I
had a strangely similar experience
although my friends told me you're done
the hardest parade is finding the right
person and I was really excited but
Nancy came back screaming Renata what do
you know about relationships
clearly not much because so far a
hundred percent of them have and it
I know but before I tell you what
happened next I want to take a quick
poll raise your hand if you think that
love is a pretty important part of life
everyone all of us great now raise your
hand if you feel like you've been really
well educated on how to love
none of us let's think about that for a
second we all value our careers and if
you're relatively well educated on how
to succeed that's how we got here but
when it comes to love which overwhelming
research points as a top predictor of
life satisfaction health and wealth we
kind of just wait or swipe until we find
the right person we look at the couples
around us we watch what they do right
and wrong and we assume we know how to
do right but that's like hoping to
become a doctor by watching Grey's
Anatomy and that's what I was thinking
about when I met John I felt like I
finally met the right person but I
didn't feel educated on how to be the
right person and I started getting
really scared that I would eventually
mess everything up and I really didn't
want to mess anything up so I started
reading every piece of research in every
book that I could find about the science
of love and relationships luckily John
loves reading so he followed me down the
rabbit hole
which is very convenient but also a
little weird now now we talk about our
relationship and feelings in terms of
stuff like attachment theory and the
neurobiology of desire and emotions and
we haven't even taken touchy-feely even
though it might not be sexy to talk
about your relationship in scientific
terms it's kind of like having food in
your teeth you really want to know so
you can do something about it I have to
say though I try to be really discreet
about my interest in relationship topics
for a long time I felt like it was too
personal controversial and frankly too
embarrassing to discuss with anyone else
bye John
but then one day my brother Rodrigo call
me to ask hey is everything okay between
you and John and I said yeah what's
going on
well my brother and I happen to share an
Amazon account which sometimes gets
awkward he was calling because he
noticed the trend in my recent book
orders seven principles for making
marriage work your brain unloved mating
in captivity and many many other
relationship hooks the John and I read
together we don't do Netflix and chill
we read and chill now when my brother
called me he was also getting an MBA so
I told him listen we're both getting an
MBA because it's valuable but it's not
always been valuable when the MBA was
created a hundred years ago people
thought it was crazy the business was
being elevated to the same level of
expertise as law and engineering now
it's the most popular degree in the u.s.
we finally see value in business
education and we have to do the same for
love now am I suggesting you create a
formal master's degree and love no but I
am suggesting we all will start seeing
ourselves as CEOs of our own love lives
we know from research that couples to
thrive and couples who fail behave very
differently we also know from research
that just like in business there is no
formula but there are tools and just
like great CEOs couples who thrive
master tools that make them better every
day today I'm gonna share my top three
favorites like a good consultant number
one choose to see love as a skill by far
the most important thing that I've
learned from this journey is that love
is not something that happens to us it's
the skill we can choose to learn
practice and master over time
it's not easy and will never be perfect
but seeing it as a skill is a first step
to getting better number two choose
generosity over judgment if you've been
the parent of a child or a puppy you
know what it feels like to see really
unpleasant behavior with generosity not
judgment you understand that they are
still growing up but if our partner does
something we don't like we judge we get
offended they should be fully grown up
by now but as long as we're alive we're
all still growing up it's easy to love
the wonderful things about a partner but
the true love skill is seeing what's not
so wonderful about them with generosity
not judgment number 3 choose to become
an expert on your partner we know from
neuroscience that if you take couples
who report to still be madly in love
after 25 years and put them through an
MRI machine when you show them a photo
of their partner their brain lights up
just like couples who just fell in love
which is crazy because that basically
means that the honeymoon phase doesn't
have to be over at the honeymoon couples
who stay in love are couples who stay
curious
every day they commit to learning about
each other like an ax breed they never
stop learning it's a bit ironic that we
find it romantic to say things like oh
my god I know everything about my
boyfriend personally I find him much
more romantic to think about how much
more I want to know about my partner and
how much more of an expert I want to
become every day now these tools are not
a checklist they're a lifelong practice
but it's easy to forget that when we get
busy with life so I want to leave you
with something that helps me remind
remind myself of being accountable every
day both in business and in love as CEOs
in love or business we're all given two
options every single day you can either
blame external conditions for your
performance or you can take radical
responsibility for practicing the skills
that make you better now the question is
which one will you choose
[Applause]
[Music]